12 est à présent face à la première
[Musique]
la collectivité territoriale la
martinique prépare un budget d'un combat
pour aussi remonter les effets néfastes
de la crise sanitaire que nous vivons le
vote interviendra d'ici deux mois les
élus de l'assemblée ont pu s'exprimer
sur la philosophie du futur budget
préparé par le conseil exécutif
c'était en fin de semaine dernière jeudi
et vendredi
un document qui alimentera certainement
la campagne électorale pour le
renouvellement les 13 et 20 g des
instances de la ctm il reste à savoir
maintenant comment cette campagne sera
organisé et si nous sommes encore au
temps limité dans notre liberté de
mouvement de déplacement
ces élections reportées dans toute la
france en raison de l'épidémie provoquée
par le virus comme et 19
permettront-elles de moderniser les
pratiques militantes et de proposer une
nouvelle offre politique je vous qu'on
pense d'évoquer tous ces sujets en
compagnie de trois élus de la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
cela dans le cadre de notre série
d'émissions sur le bilan et les
perspectives de l'institution c'est le
neuvième épisode aujourd'hui bienvenue
dans face à la première en ce dimanche
28 février pour un nouveau numéro de
l'émission politique hebdomadaire de la
rédaction de martinique en première nous
inviter à cette émission réalisée par
claudine et l obligeant le bongo pendant
le fameux tic coran bernabé bonjour
madame bernabé bonjour monsieur parti et
bonjour aux auditeurs de martinique les
premières je vous remercie d'avoir
accepté notre invitation parce que votre
parole est plutôt rare vous êtes
conseiller à l'assemblée de martinique
est lui dans le groupe de l'opposition
dans les rangs de la coalition ensemble
pour une martinique nouvelle vous êtes
agronome de profession du maîtrise
technique dans une distillerie au quart
mais nous ne citerons pas son nom et
président est également de la
coopérative valcke a causé l'une des
coopératives de cacao culture et cacao
culte ris c'est comme ça sans doute pour
lutter tout à fait on peut dire ça de
martinique qui qui s'attelle à essayer
de relancer une filière cacao
d'excellence sur le territoire voilà et
que vous êtes avec une trousse également
puisque vous même vous produisez cette
denrée précieuse
je signale ne sais pas si c'est
important mais pourquoi pas que vous
êtes la benjamine de l'assemblée
vous vous aurez 32 ans vous avez été élu
à 26 ans
il y a un peu plus de cinq ans
maintenant donc nous allons parler de
votre expérience tout à l'heure et je
signale ça c'est important pour moi je
que vous êtes originaire du quart des
parents de la femme par ordre
alphabétique toujours marié l'ennemi
autun bonjour madame me au t1 moi je
m'empare thibault jose auditeurs et
auditrices vous êtes membre du conseil
exécutif de la ctm en charge de la
culture et du patrimoine
vous êtes une militante du cncp lemay
conseil national des communautés
populaires l'une des formations du camp
indépendantiste aux et historienne et
vous avez longtemps exercé la profession
de professeur d'histoire et géographie
je rappelle que vous avez publié
plusieurs ouvrages ou brochures sur
l'histoire économique social et
politique de la lentille nique et vous
est implanté au françois
c'est tout à fait sage a précisément du
cncp mouvement assez plairait un
objectif
la précision est importante et enfin
diane montrose bonjour madame montrose
bonjour monsieur parti et malheureuse du
tri ses auditeurs de la première
conseillère à l'assemblée de martinique
vous également vous êtes élus de la
majorité militante de bas pays en chance
le mouvement présidé par yan monplaisir
et vous présidez entre autres au titre
de la 7e la société publique locale
aménagement et équipement qui oeuvre
pour le compte de la 7eme c'est bien ça
pour le corps de la ctm de cap nord et
puis maintenant de 20 communes de
martinique alors société publique locale
c'est l'année
nouvelle forme de société d'économie
mixte en quelque sorte on peut dire ça
alors c'est pas tout à fait pareil parce
que les sociétés d'économie mixte ont un
partenariat public privé alors que les
sociétés publiques locales non pour
actionnaires que des collectivités
publiques
et puis une sem répond marché aux appels
d'offres et peut travailler sur le
territoire mais aussi à l'extérieur
c'est le cas de la semsamar oda semag
une société publique locale ne peut
travailler que pour ses actionnaires et
que sur leur territoire et en plus elle
a un objet social bien déterminé les
canaris l'aménagement aménagements
équipements tout à fait voilà donc je
signale que vous êtes implantée à
fort-de-france d'ailleurs nous avons le
nord le sud et le centre représente
aujourd'hui est également trois
générations de femmes politiques coran
bernabé qui commence son apprentissage
puisque c'est votre premier mandat d'élu
donc au sein de l'assemblée de
martinique depuis décembre 2015
et puis face à vous marier la nuit au
teint qui elle a un engagement militant
disons plus anciens et donc vous avez
d'ailleurs marié les nouveautés on en a
parlé là quelques semaines quelques
jours participer activement à la grande
grève à l'école de chabrits février 1974
alors il faut préciser quand même jeu
j'étais à bordeaux et je terminais mes
études ce sont d'autres camarades qui
sont entrés en travaux moi donc j'ai pas
participé à moi même physiquement à
cette grève n'est de bordeaux si nous
soutenions cette grève d avons eu
l'occasion de participer dans l'ubs soit
l'union de soutien aux ouvriers
agricoles en envoyant des sommes
d'argent des pour les ouvriers agricoles
les familles en grève
alors avant de rentrer dans le vif du
sujet sur la 7ème et notamment sur la
dernière plénière et puis surtout sur la
campagne électorale et les élections à
venir vous avez mesdames tous deux
suivis de près ou de loin je ne sais le
carnaval qu'est ce que vous en avez
pensé de ces vides et spontanée sauvage
ou marron comme certains les appeler
selon son point de vue est-ce qu'il
fallait laisser les personnes qui le
souhaitaient organiser les vider comme
ça s'est passé ou au contraire respecter
les consignes
l'interdiction édictée par le préfet et
quelques maires dont ils n'étaient pas
très nombreux mais quelques maires en
sus du robert de schoelcher de
fort-de-france et du lamentin ont été
inspirés par des livres évidés sur le
territoire de la commune coran bernabé
oui il y avait il ya certes des normes
sanitaires à respecter après quand on
voit comment ce qui s'est passé
finalement comment les choses se sont
déroulées
peut-être qu'il aurait fallu en un mot
peut-être organiser quelque chose avec
avec les les autorités enfin les
associations finalement qui qui
participe à l'organisation du carnaval
pour pouvoir accompagner au mieux
l'événement ce qui finalement n'a pas pu
se faire en l'état
dieu m'offre aux gars écoutez je pense
que on a vu ce qui s'est passé pendant
le carnaval les martiniquais fait le
choix de participer au carnaval ils ont
manifesté l'attachement qu'ils avaient à
cet événement culturel
ils ont manifesté aussi un choix qui est
celui d'un carnaval on a l'habitude
d'avoir
et qui n'est pas un carnaval organisé en
fermer mais qu'est ce qu'on tanner qui
rassemble tout le monde alors c'est
compliqué dans ce contexte sanitaire
c'est vrai mais je crois que ça
participe aussi parfois de l'incohérence
dans les décisions qui sont prises
peut-être de l'incohérence et puis de la
non compréhension aussi ou de la non
adhésion en tout cas aux décisions qui
sont prises souvent quand les décisions
qui sont données ne sont pas comprises
ne sont pas acceptés de tous aiment bien
ça conduit ça conduit à ça c'est le
genre de situation marie-hélène les
hôtes et il fallait continuer d'
interdit le carnaval empêcher aux gens
de se défiler de s'amuser ne laissez pas
tout à fait comme ça les gens sont un
peu plus complexes
il ya ce qui s'est passé au stade de
dillon dont je dirais csii
y pas beau simplement mais l'année
prochaine
il faut pas qu'ils utilisent l'argent de
nos impôts pour faire ce qui s'est passé
a dit laurent parce qu'on peut de vue
public c'est une échec total et il le
reconnaît ce jeudi il
c'est la ville de fort de france d'autre
part dieu commence ça ceci dit ce que
fait les vies des marots je dis que
s'ils ont des doutes quand même je
demande qu'il fasse un test afin qu'ils
auraient dû le faire depuis parce que
c'est pas nous ont 3 e mail mais
j'espère que ceux qui ont des doutes
qu'ils ont fait un test après le ovi des
marots c'est tout ce que je peux dire
alors on veut non pas des choses disons
plus d'actualité c'est vrai que les
élections sont reportées
théoriquement elle devrait avoir lieu le
13 juin jeudi théorie qu'en pense qu il
faut encore l'avis du conseil
scientifique nationale 1 qui conseille
qui informe le gouvernement qui va
décider ou pas de proposer au parlement
de maintenir les élections en chef ou de
le reporter qu'est ce que vous en pensez
mais dame faut-il absolument faire les
élections en juin en dépit de la crise
sanitaire de l'épidémie dont on ne sait
pas quelle tournure elle va prendre ou
au contraire misé sur la prudence et
puis se dire comment finalement mais
nous comptons vrai que monet malaga où
les corps à bernabeu je crois que la
question est délicate aujourd'hui il
faut voir je pense en fonction d'eux
de chaque territoire comment la crise
sanitaire
la situation sanitaire à évoluer en
fonction prendre les décisions
on n'a pas encore les retours ont
peut-être des effets 2d et fait qu'on a
peut-être eu suite suite au carnaval
et puis de ce qui va se passer dans
l'est dans les semaines ou les mois à
venir si la situation le permet au
niveau sanitaire mais il faudra prendre
les précautions en hameaux pour à mon
avis oui mettre en place un scrutin tout
en respectant les normes sanitaires
mondiales montrent aux mêmes analyses
oui a lancé vrai que la loi est senti un
récemment c'est vrai qu'on a pris fixer
une date d'élection mais c'est vrai
aussi il faut le dire qu'on a
le conseil scientifique qui lui devra se
prononcer le 1er avril et qui va devoir
effectivement fixer une date
mais je crois qu'on a affaire à une
crise qui est sans précédent et donc il
n'ya pas de recette il n'y a pas de mode
opératoire il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas
de référence donc c'est compliqué de
prendre une décision dans ce contexte là
et les élections qui vont avoir lieu
sont des élections qui doivent avoir
lieu de façon nationale bon et donc ça
n'est pas que la situation de la
martinique qui compte la situation de la
gwadeloup va compter la situation de la
gouaille de la guyane va compter mais ce
qui se passe aussi aux alpes maritimes
où ils vivent confinement ça aussi ça va
compter pour fixer une date
et puis on a vu ce qui s'est passé lors
des dernières élections municipales où
on a voulu effectivement à tout prix
pouvoir donner une date est posée une
date
ça a posé de problème le problème de la
mobilisation et de l'abstention inquiète
toujours
le premier gagnant depuis un certain
nombre d'années des élections il faut se
poser des questions véritablement pas
que par rapport à la crise mais par
rapport à l'intérêt et puis le deuxième
problème que ça a posé moins 100
martinique on n'a pas trop vu mais je
veux quand même rappeler qu en hexagone
ça a pesé quand même un problème
conséquent puisque ceux qui avaient tenu
des bureaux de vote se sont retrouvés
dans des situations où ils ont été
atteints pour beaucoup du coc vite on a
vu des reportages là dessus donc il faut
les organiser
mais il faut bien les organiser et puis
ça suppose aussi que l'état donne les
moyens aux communes qui sont déjà assez
exemplaire en matière de finances pour
organiser des élections les gens se
sentent rassurés
sinon ne fera qu augmenter l'abstention
alors justement parlant de l'abstention
marylène et hôtels la campagne
électorale pour les municipales de
l'année diack enfin le second tour s'ils
ont tous en juin à montré que
l'abstention atteint du rock ans ici
également
est ce que les états majors politiques
ont pris le son qui ont tiré les leçons
de cette difficulté de se déplacer
d'aller chez les électrices et des
électeurs pour envisager un nouveau type
de campagne électorale pour ces
sélections si par exemple de nôtre mais
s'il ya beaucoup d'abstention ce n'est
pas dû aux difficultés de faire une
campagne électorale est aujourd'hui il
ya mille façons d'entrer en contact avec
les électeurs pour porter les formations
nous ne maîtrisons pas le calendrier
électoral c'est le gouvernement qui
choisit à la date des élections
et quelle que soit la date retenue nous
serons prêts ceci dit j'espère que joue
en france on arrivera à faire des
élections
un autre jour que le dimanche ça se fait
déjà ici le santé est pour certaines
élections ou un sou plusieurs jours ou
envisager le vote par correspondance
aussi ou envisager un vote électronique
on va vers la modernisation donc
j'espère qu'un jour la france va casser
ce système qui oblige à faire des
élections sont un seul jo le dimanche et
d'une seule façon il faut aller vers des
procédures plus moderne le début
beaucoup mais plusieurs pays qui
organisent les actions en semaine en
effect vous voulez ajouter quelque chose
qu on a mis la question est-ce que
l'abstention étant liés que ça au mode
de scrutin
python plutôt coquin
forme d intéressement ou et toute la
population à la chose politique
la population se désintéresse de plus en
plus de la chose politique pour certains
hommes d'horizons qui serait trop longue
à exprimer c'est pourquoi pour vous
qu'est-ce qui quel est le principal
obstacle pour qu'ils expliquent le
prouver que l'abstention la population
se désintéresse parce que bien souvent
il ya des hommes ou des femmes
politiques qui a eu des comportements
qui sont pas acceptables de qui
finissent par vous dit ils se sont tous
des voleurs tous des cours on peut tous
des sites où ce dessin dockers ya
effectivement des go et la population se
désintéresse mais c'est lié bien souvent
au comportement de certains parce que
c'est passé pas la majorité
andré aliker est un homme politique on a
justement il est mort parce qu'il a
dénoncé un scandale de corruption
doc mais on n'a qu'à gaza s'il ya une ou
deux brebis galeuses on a tendance à
généraliser sur tout le monde donc il
faut aussi avoir un comportement
exemplaire pour que la population fasse
confiance à à des femmes et des hommes
politiques qui portent un projet qui
répond aux qui répondent aux besoins
réels de la population d'après vaux
d'yonne montrose qu'est ce qui empêchait
nos lectrices et lecteurs de faire
l'effort de d'écouté de choisir parmi
les programmes les projets quelle que
soit l'élection est finalement d'aller
aux yeux qu'est-ce qui parce qu'il ya la
moitié seulement des électeurs qui ont
voté pour au premier tour pour les
élections territoriales
un peu plus ce second tour comme
d'habitude on voit de plus au second
compromettons ici comme ailleurs mais
bon c'est ce n'est qu' un électeur sur
deux oui oui et et ça pose sa poste
véritablement un problème sur
effectivement la représentativité bon
mais vous savez j'ai tendance à regarder
les choses en ne regardant pas que
l'autre mais à nous remettre en question
aussi
alors certes marie-hélène à a évoqué l'
exemplarité
mais je crois que de moins en moins
les gens se sentent concernés par ce que
le message que le rôle qu'on leur
adresse
peut-être qu'ils ne se sentent pas
touchés par ce message
peut-être qu'on espère plus peut-être
qu'on désillusionnent et peut-être qu'à
un moment donné il faut peut-être
arrêter de dire ce qu'on va faire mais
simplement de faire et faire parce que
ça suppose alors je dis plus que faire
ce qu'on a dit faire
savez vous avez parlé de la dernière
plénière mais des plans des idées des
projets des schémas il y en a des
centaines et des centaines maintenant
faire c'est à dire avoir une vision
globale dire aux gens où va mais pas
être en réaction
en réaction par rapport à l'actualité
parce que la réaction c'est ce qui va
peut-être nous permettre de conquérir
les votes la prochaine fois d'être dans
l'action
l'action s'est projeté à 10 20 30 ans
dire aux gens où on veut aller et puis à
10 20 30 ans met des étapes se donner
rendez-vous à atteindre des objectifs
revenir vers les gens leur dire ce qu'on
a fait leurs dix ans pourquoi on a
échoué
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas marché avoir le
courage de corriger quand ça n'a pas
marché parce que oui on n'a pas la
science infuse mais c'est justement
parce qu'on n'a pas la science infuse
qu'il ne faut pas à mon avis se priver
de l'intelligence collective qu'on
regarde à bitche que vous acquiescez
mais un particulier à une phrase que
viennent prononcé diane montrose
peut-être que les gens ne se sentent pas
concernés par ce que nous les
responsables politiques nous faisons
nous nous disons est ce que vous qu'il
faisait partie de la jeunesse puisque
vous avez moins de 40 ans vous sentez
autour de vous ce manque d'intérêt ou ce
désintérêt ou ce je m'en fiche isme
des jeunes pour la chose politique e
je dirais premièrement ça va peut-être
que ça dépend ça ça dépend des jeunes ce
n'est pas je pense qu'il ne faut pas
localisé en fait ça mais il ya une chose
en fait que je constate depuis les cinq
petites années 1 où je suis en politique
c'est que on peint souvent on rentre
dans un monde et on perd la réalité du
terrain et c'est vrai j'acquiesce ce que
ça que vient de dian diallo il faut il
faut être dans l'action c'est à dire il
ya plein de plans des schémas avancées
réglementaires on est obligé de les
faire il faut les mettre en place de
toute façon et derrière il faut il faut
aussi et pas que il faut il faut
vraiment le faire mettre en place les
actions qui doivent suivre finalement
tous ces schémas
tous ces schémas qu'on m'a écrit et puis
au delà de ça il ya la question de la
présence et de notre présence sur le
terrain mais au delà la présence est pas
que allez je suis dans le secteur de
l'agriculture à les rencontrer des
agriculteurs et bien oui je vous
soutiens non c'est quelque part en garde
est finalement un pied dans dans le
monde économique on va dire ça comme ça
à lorient dans le réel c'est c'est une
façon aussi de bain peut-être de mieux
comprendre ce qu'on ce qu'on peut faire
au mieux pour prendre le territoire et
je crois que c'est super important
alors justement c'est important d'accord
mais est ce que vous sentez cet intérêt
ce que j'aime tourner vous encore qu'il
ne faille pas globaliser pose des
questions s'informent veulent savoir ce
qui se fait à la 7e ou bien à la commune
est-ce que vous avez ces témoignages
autour de vous deux jeunes femmes de
jeunes hommes qui s'intéressent à la vie
publique finalement je vous dirai encore
une fois ça dépend y en a qui
s'intéresse il y en a qui vont
s'intéresser à la vie publique mais en
disant oui s'il ya quelque chose qui se
fait il faut pas que ça se fasse
comme comme ce qu'on a l'habitude de
voir avec des plaignants qui comme enfin
qui sont censées commencer à 18 heures
du matin mais quitter qui terminent
entre minuit et 2 heures du matin parce
que parce que pour la plupart ce sont ce
sont des jeunes qui travaillent qui ont
une vie de famille etc
et je crois que en ce sens et peut-être
qu'à la crise sanitaire nous invite à ça
il faut un peu repenser de penser la
chose politique la façon de faire
alors tiens puisque vous parlez le
plaignant se soumettant dès la page
merci madame bernabé lave dernier en
séance plénière jeudi et vendredi 6 à
montrer que nous sommes vraiment dans le
nous avons compris la nécessité enfin
les élus ont compris la nécessité de
tirer parti de la crise sanitaire pour
réorienter toute la société
martiniquaise est ainsi les orientations
budgétaires ont été l'objet de débats je
ne veux pas dire dans le consensus parce
qu'il ya eu des désaccords il ya eu des
questions et vidéos vindication par
exemple john man 3 avait souligné je
vous entendu parler des efforts
méritoires que la septème va mettre en
avant pour lutter contre les agressions
sexuelles contre les femmes et contre
les enfants
apparemment vous avez été sensibilisés à
ça parce que peut-être que le système ne
faisait pas ne fait pas jusqu'à présent
suffisamment si vous souhaitez la cie
c'est exactement ce que disait courage
tout à l'heure on ne fait pas pour les
gens au fait avec les gens alors ce
qu'on a souligné dans ce débat
d'orientation budgétaire et il faut le
souligner parce que en tout cas les
administratifs au fait un gros travail
108 pages c'est l'un des jobs qui était
le plus étoffé de toute notre mandature
donc il ya eu un gros travail de fait de
la part des administratifs dans ce qui
nous a été présenté
on a quand même regretter encore une
fois que nous n'ayons pas construit ses
orientations budgétaires ensemble des
orientations budgétaires c'est quoi
c'est dire aux gens là où on va mettre
l'accent là où on va mettre le paquet on
définit d'abord là où on va mettre les
priorités et en fonction des priorités
qu'on a défini après on met le budget en
place la deuxième étape le mois a priori
qui devrait se passer le mois prochain
bon très bien voilà on a fait on a pas
qu'au construit et souvent quand on se
désintéressent de la politique c'est
parce qu'on se désintéresse souvent de
ce qui fait vivre les gens de ce qui les
anime
oui j'ai souligné le fait que ça serait
intéressant qu'on s'intéresse aux gens
véritablement parce que vous savez c'est
bon on a construit les routes
on a fait les bâtiments ça existe il ya
des infrastructures encore faut-il
qu'elle soit maintenue est ce qu'à un
moment donné on peut s'occuper
véritablement des personnes de leur
épanouissement
et bien si on s'occupe des personnes et
des rip à nice mans c'est ce que j'ai eu
l'occasion de souligner en plénière et
bien faut accentuer ce qu'on a fait pour
la lutte contre les inégalités sociales
quand on décide quand sylvia sa soutane
prépare ce projet pour faire en sorte
que chaque élève est une tablette
je lutte contre l'inégalité sociale
lorsqu'elle travaille sur un projet pour
faire en sorte que l'on habite à grande
rivière ou à saint pierre
on paye le même prix de cantine je lutte
contre les inégalités sociales et je
fais en sorte qu'une maman qui a
plusieurs enfants ne soient pas obligées
de d'essayer de de voir comment elle
peut faire pour qu'ils aillent à l'école
et qu'il mange parce qu'elle peut
peut-être pas nourrir les deux ou les
trois et c'est important quand je dis ça
alors peut-être que ça peut surprendre
mais la lutte contre les inégalités
sociales la lutte contre
le vivre ensemble la lutte contre le les
injustices parce que quand je parle du
viol de l'inceste
nous avons des associations un tissu
associatif qui travaillent au quotidien
depuis des années c'est ce que j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire en plénière j'ai
parlé notamment de l'âme vie de fabienne
sainte-rose heureusement qui a pris
cette cause de l'inceste à bras le corps
et qui aujourd'hui est bien tant mieux
si on découvre que ça existe et tant
mieux si on les accompagne
parce que on s'est bien rendu compte
pendant la crise sanitaire que lorsqu'on
pouvait pas joindre directement être en
contact avec la population
nous sommes passés par les associations
ne faut pas pensent pas à penser à eux
qu en période de crise
voilà donc c'est un pas en tant qu on
ait une une volonté politique forte de
soutenir le tissu associatif
voilà face à la 1er jean mas parti
marianne l'année au teint membres du
conseil exécutif est ce que vous
acquiescez à l'idée ceux de diane
montrant selon laquelle ce document
d'orientation budgétaire qui fixe les
caps pour le budget qui sera voté dans
quelques semaines n'a pas été co
construit n'a pas été élaborée
suffisamment en concertation avec tous
les groupes tous les élus de quelque
nature qu'il soit oui je veux revenir
sur ce que diane montrose a dit tout à
l'heure
elle a dit il faut faire effectivement
et je porte le bilan de cette première
c'était émission veux je le porte aussi
que tout le conseil exécutif et toute la
majorité qui a été élu en décembre 2015
john trois à parler de des projets de
sylvia sa soutane
mais elle n'est pas toute seule elle est
dans un conseil exécutif et les membres
du conseil exécutif comme moi même et
c'est le conseil exécutif qui portent
ces propositions et qui sont ensuite
voté à la majorité au sein de
l'assemblée
donc c'est une majorité qui portent ces
projets et lorsqu'on dit il faut faire
je vais vous donner deux exemples
justement et puis j'avais pas lu un peu
aussi de la culture puisque je suis
quand même responsable de la culture
il ya eu des ya des besoins exprimés par
la population parfois depuis des
dizaines d'années et nous avons essayé
de répondre à ses besoins en termes de
cohésion sociale de réduction des
inégalités d'équipement du territoire et
cetera je vous donne deux exemples le
premier exaucé le lycée schoelcher
emblématique depuis les années 2000
le conseil régional a voté pour la
démolition reconstruction du lycée
schoelcher regard fêtant les choses ont
traîné
on se demandait même mais est-ce qu'un
jour on va y arriver
et bien la dernière mandature fait la
dernière du conseil régional où j'étais
présente en 2010 nous n'avons même pas
été capable de terminer le lycée de
transit en place et elle est arrivée
nous avons fait le lycée de transit sous
la plateforme de la pointe des
vous avez quatre lycées qui cohabitent
là nous avons démoli et nous avons
reconstruit le lycée schoelcher
moi de jeu 2021 le chantier est terminé
et nous avons terminé aussi le bâtiment
victo faucha de cette mandature en fête
ses cinq ans on peut dire de mandature
ça c'est un des matériaux doute pour ce
qui touche en fait et on a répondu à des
besoins exprimés depuis des dizaines
d'années et qu'est ce que le deuxième
exemple c'est martinique transport
évidemment c'est pas tellement le tcsp
bien le décès est ce que la danse soit
mais c'est d'avoir mis à plat cette
autorité unique pour le transport ce qui
a facilité beaucoup de choses parce que
y'a début d'organisation des transports
dans le nord ce qui n'existait pas et
puis vous avez également le sud qui est
raccordé à la gare de carrière ce qui
n'existait pas non plus nous avons fait
ça et là ses besoins exprimés là aussi
depuis des dizaines d'années on avait
l'impression qu'on n'y arriverait jamais
la septième en cinq ans elle a répondu à
ces deux besoins mais je n'ai pas le
bruit de la culture mais quand même que
ce que voulaient démontrer par là de la
mesure où ça faisait partie de la route
de la feuille de mission
voilà c'est une majorité qui avaient un
programme qu'elle a présentée et nous a
dit nous sommes arrivés à
l'aboutissement d'un processus d'auto
parlait depuis des dizaines d'années et
on n'arrivait pas abouti donc nous avons
rempli notre contrat nous avons rempli
notre feuille de route
nous avons fait donc c'est bien ce que
donne notre os 10 et elle fait partie de
cette majorité qui a fait j'ai donné ces
deux exemples à lisser cherchait des
transports mais dans le domaine de la
culture
là aussi on arrive au bout d'un
processus depuis les années 80 il ya
quelque chose qui se passe en martinique
c'est ce que j'appelle une consolidation
de nos trois conscience martiniquaise
notre conscience identitaire notre
conscience historique et il arrive un
moment où il faut laisser des traces à
c'est ce que nous avons fait avec notre
programme qui concerne dix ans la
mémoire d'une façon générale le monument
à des clients
sur les traces d un sujet on entre et de
terminer ce programme là et j'ai dit que
il faut laisser des traces dans le
domaine de la mémoire
on ne pouvait pas non plus continuer
continuer à parler par exemple il a
démoli déboulonner la statue de
joséphine sous la savane nous nous avons
refait le parcours de visite au musée de
l'ap hp
nous avons refait ça et il est ouvert là
tout le monde peut aller voir
nous avons mis l'accent sur la présence
esclaves sous cette habitation souris
c'est beau c'est d'abord ça n'a pas ri
avant d'être le lieu de naissance de
joséphine c'est d'abord une habitation
sicogi qui a compté jusqu'à 300 esclaves
au xviiie siècle
donc ce n'était pas une petite elle
était parmi les grandes habitations
le dernier exemple que je donne pour la
culture c'est le mahatma ça fait des
années depuis les années 80 quand on a
constitué le fonds régional d'art
contemporain
nous avons des oeuvres d'art qui sont
enfermés dans le sous-sol de bâtiments
que personne ne voit nos artistes
plasticiens nous demandaient depuis des
dizaines d'années mais quand est ce que
vous allez faire un musée beaucoup plus
exposés ce qu'on sait faire mais aussi
beaucoup la jeune création martiniquaise
puisse aussi s'exprimer
donc c'est de là qu'est partie la
décision de faire le magma nous
répondons à un besoin et c'est en route
et en plus nous réhabilitons du
patrimoine
lassé palais de justice également la
villa des bosquets l'ancienne demeure du
roi ben c'est donc c'est ça faire
remplir au contrat comment musée d'art
contemporain de la martinique pour ceux
qui ne sont pas familiers avec le sigle
relativement récent relativement nouveau
corps à berlin mais qu'est-ce que vous
ça ça ça vous est ce que vous venez
d'entendre de j'allais dire aider on me
dit que ces voix mais est-ce que vous
même donne en plus vous êtes dans
l'opposition vous ne la fait pas
d'impatience devant les difficultés de
faire justement les retards les
ralentissements les frais les obstacles
qui se dressent dans la septième en
interne et en externe et déjà pour
réagir aux propos précédents ce que je
pourrais dire c'est que par rapport à ce
dont on parlait tout à l'heure en fait
pour moi les gens ils ont ils en ont
assez d'entendre c'est moi qui ai fait
notre n'a pas fait il aurait dû j'aurais
pas pu faire
f voilà aujourd'hui c'est ont fait et on
fait on fait pas parce que c'est nous
qui faisons et parce qu'on a besoin
d'eux enfin voilà de se sentir être
reconnus ont fait parce que parce qu'on
a envie de faire pour le territoire on
en parle ce qu'on aime nos territoires
on a envie de le voir avancer et
finalement quel quel que soit ce qu'on a
ce qu'on a en face quelle que soit la
personne qu'on a en face de nous à
partir du moment où on est dans des
projets qui sont viables et intéressant
pour le territoire
il faut y aller et et le lycée
schoelcher et martinique transports et
tout ça mais mais c'est génial mais on
pc de la continuité ce ne sont pas des
projets qui date d'il ya cinq ans ou dix
lits à 10 ans aux mêmes d'il ya 15 ans
comme l'a dit marionnettes on l'est on
est dans la continuité
et oui il aboutit cela et tant mieux
qu'ils aboutissent tant mieux parce que
j'ai déniché ce qu'il faut reconnaître
ils ont abouti avec la mode lecture
c'est elle
ils ont abouti je sais alors que ça fait
des dizaines d'années on avait
l'impression qu'on n'y arriverai jamais
mais ils n'aboutissent pas peut-être pas
parce que c'est la mandature c'était
mais parce que c'est vous m'aimez
certainement parce que ce sont deux
parce que c'est une succession de
personnes qui ont eu envie de faire ces
choses-là sur le territoire et ça
aboutit aujourd'hui et c'est très bien
mais mes essais et je crois que c'est ce
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut regarder aussi
pont demain c'est qu'est ce qu'on a
envie
concrètement pour notre territoire sans
regarder qui a en face qui a eu ce qu'a
eue avant ce cas pas eu avant on
capitalise aujourd'hui on a quoi ok mon
bain allons avancer à partir de ce
kiosque de ce conte de ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui sur sur ce qu'on a envie de
voir demain pour nos territoires
dieng 3,8 à fait vous avez des questions
je fais je voulais simplement réagir
parce que quand on dit qu'il faut faire
ça veut pas dire qu'on porte une
critique oui le lycée schoelcher a été
femme et personne ne le nie je n'ai pas
nier ici c'était pas mon propos oui on a
mis en place martin transport et puis
bon s'il faut parler du lycée schoelcher
je pourrais certainement vous en parler
puisque effectivement c'était la sodem
qui avaient ce chantier en charge et
l'ensemble des plans qui ont servi à la
construction
ont été signés de mes mains à et la
démolition là du premier bâtiment jeter
présenter ce étaient encore menés par la
sodem avant sa liquidation
et tant mieux si on avance
j'ai pas l'habitude aujourd'hui de
critiquer ce qu'ils ont fait aux fins
avec les moyens qu'ils avaient ils n'ont
pas poursuivi
ils n'ont pas achevé quand on est en
responsabilité et quand on arrive on
assume à la fois l'actif ce cas de bon
et on assume à la fois le passif il n'y
a pas d'actifs s'il n'y a pas de passif
donc si ça s'est arrêté au milieu du
pont ah ben il faut qu'on traverse le
pont voilà
mais en tout cas c'est c'est justement
ça ne pas considérer que parce que c'est
l'autre qui avait proposé mais c'est pas
bon mais à la poubelle et on recommence
sinon on est dans un éternel
recommencement sans fin sans aucune
réalisation
donc quand je dis faire quand vous avez
parlé de la plénière
quand on a voté le principe du pas
demain en 2017 et que le diagnostic qui
va servir à élaborer le padma est posée
en 2021
j'ai un soucis j'ai un souci quand on a
une collègue de l'assemblée
madame renard qui a proposé que l'on
puisse mettre en place un plan
alimentaire et que ça a été voté il y a
deux ans et que deux ans après quand on
pose la question on ne sait pas nous
dire comment ça a commencé j'ai un souci
quand on a tous voté le fait que les
entreprises martiniquaises
il fallait les soutenir et vous savez
soutenir c'est quoi quand je parle de
lutte contre les inégalités
je veut bien m'expliquer ici aujourd'hui
on a tout le monde parle du problème du
dépeuplement des jeunes qui parlent mais
quand ils reviennent
est ce qu'ils se sentent soutenus celui
qui n'est pas né avec une cuillère en
argent dans la bouche
est-ce qu'il a le sentiment d'avoir les
mêmes chances que l'autre c'est notre
rôle c'est notre responsabilité et donc
quand on met en place le fonds générés
mis pour que lorsque les personnes qui
ont des
idée des bonnes idées qui se sont formés
qui veulent revenir mais qui n'ont pas
les moyens financiers et bas que par ce
système on puisse injecter de l'argent
au capital et qu'on met pas en place le
vous croyez qu'on peut se contenter de
se dire ok john j'ai fait non on peut
pas être satisfait quand on est en
responsabilité s'ils se remettent tout
le temps en question mais ça fait partie
du jeu il faut accepter ça mais ça
n'enlève pas ce qu'on a fait ça n'enlève
pas ce qui a de bien mais je veux dire
est ce que ma mission je les remplis
est-ce que mémé mais est ce que c'est en
même temps dans cette mandature qu'on a
le le plus grand nombre de personnes qui
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté mais
c'est pas moi qui le dit donc est-ce
qu'on accepte quand même un petit peu
est ce que c'est de se remettre en
question est ce qu'on l'a s'était mis
responsable de l'appauvrissement de la
population
je vais vous dire une chose sur
l'appauvrissement de la population savez
vous avez parlé de la plénière hier et
on parlait notamment du de la gestion du
rsa et de la deûle delà de la convention
de gestion du rsa est revenu la
problématique notamment de cette gestion
lourde pour une collectivité où nous a
données à gérer sans nous donner les
moyens
et finalement on à 900 millions qui ne
sont pas compensés par le rsa et on
parle de recentraliser le rsa très bien
on a vécu un col vide avec des jeunes
qui étaient en difficulté qui nous ont
interpellé alors certes un conseiller a
parlé du rsa jeunes actifs mais comment
on peut faire pour nos jeunes à nous qui
ne sont pas jeunes actifs qui sont
simplement étudiants mais qui n'ont pas
les moyens d'étudier comme les autres
est ce que dans l'initiative
on peut imaginer qu'on puisse mettre en
place nous le rsa jeunes je parle pas
des bourses encore une fois mon va
médias mais on a fait les bourses on a
mis les bouts je ne parle pas de ça il
ya des jeunes qui ont envie d'aller plus
loin mais leurs mamans et leurs parents
ne peuvent pas financer
quand je lutte contre les des
peuplements est bien ce que je dis quand
je veux lutter contre le dépeuplement
il ya deux raisons
au dépeuplement oui il ya les jeunes qui
partent mais il ya aussi la politique
familiale est ce qu'on a mis en place
une politique de soutien familial
comment je fais pour regagner la
fécondité parce que les jeunes ne font
pas de parents mes écrits
il faut qu'on colle à la réalité quand
on est médecin
quand on est infirmière quand on
travaille à la police quand on travaille
dans une station service
quand on travaille dans un hypermarché
est confiné à 20 heures j'ai envie
peut-être d'avoir des enfants mais j'ai
pas crèche au delà de 17 heures qu'est
ce qu'on met en place pour regagner la
natalité pour faire en sorte que quand
je vis en martinique
je sens que mes enfants sont importants
regarder le paysage
dites moi où vous avez départ pour les
enfants de moins de 7 ans dites-moi fait
la liste en dehors de quand vous avez
des enfants moi j'en ai 4 je peux en
parler quand en dehors d'aller sur la
place de chaires ou alors sur le malecon
dites-moi si j'habite quelque part est
ce que je sens que mon enfant compte que
tout est misé là dessus parce que on
peut pas parler que du dépeuplement
sans parler du fait que et bien on a
plus peut-être envie de faire des
enfants parce que ça nous paraît trop
difficile parce que voilà joindre les
deux bouts c'est pas facile donc je suis
pas dans la critique j'ai justement je
veux qu'on sorte de ça on n'est pas dans
la critique du jeu
je veux simplement rappeler ce que j'ai
dit simplement parce que c'est un peu
mal interprétés
notre mandature a eu le privilège
d'arriver au terme d'efforts réalisés
depuis des décennies auparavant pour
mettre en place une autorité unique du
transport par exemple et moderniser
l'organisation des transports donc il
faut effectivement remercié tous ceux
qui ont participé auparavant à ce
travail mais il arrive un moment où il
faut justement arrivé au bout du
processus et c'est ce que la ctm a fait
c'est ce que j'ai dit tout simplement je
ne critique personne mais je constate
que nous avons peut arriver au bout de
processus dans des exemples que j'ai
donné pour la culture les transports et
le lycée
chez le chien sequana fécondité
rapidement s'il ya un problème est que
la population de la martinique diminue
ce qui est le cas de tous les pays de la
caraïbe et donc ne sont pas une
exception de cuba à trinidad la
population diminue c'est parce que les
couches en âge de travailler et de
procréer s'en vont c'est tout y a pas de
problèmes de fécondité a menti dit qu on
fait des enfants comme de tous les pays
qui sont quand même un petit peu moudden
et urbanisé la fécondité va chuter même
en afrique le taux de natalité baisse
mais nous nous couche un âge de
propriété en faut c'est ce qui fait la
baisse de la natalité
simplement il n'y a pas de problème de
vieillissement c'est une bonne chose ça
veut dire que nos populations lg encore
bonne santé jusqu'à un certain âge
donc on a quand même une couverture
sanitaire qui est à peu près correct
après je ne dis pas qu'on a tous fait
qu'on a tous réalisés il reste beaucoup
à réaliser mais il faut continuer dans
ce sens là bon alors parlons un peu de
l'avenir parce que nous avons tous qu'un
peu de temps avant la fin de mission
cours à berne abc déjà est-ce que vous
êtes candidat pour un nouveau mandat
on ne sait pas comment les élections en
tournée vous risquez d'être au conseil
exécutif
au contraire la dans la majorité ou
encore dans l'opposition nouveau bref
est ce que vous êtes candidats pourront
repartir pour un nouveau mandat de six
ans c'est une très bonne question que je
me pose encore aujourd'hui
du coup très honnêtement je suis je suis
comédien ravi de l'expérience des 5 face
aux six dernières années écoulées et
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses et je
pense qu'on peut faire beaucoup de
choses en fait avec avec la politique
sur nos territoires en tout cas qu'on
peut qu'on peut amener de la
structuration pour le territoire
quels que soient les domaines et et s'il
y a
si si j'ai encore la possibilité de le
faire pour les cinq ou six prochaines
années à venir
pourquoi pas oui voilà pourquoi je vous
pose la question parce que imaginons un
peu de politique fiction que vous êtes
présidente du conseil exécutif la roja
prochain quel sera votre priorité
prioritaire si je puis dire mais tu pas
très objective sur l'antique ce sera
bien entendu l'agriculture
mais voilà en france en face des
affaires sociales parce que je pense que
freins comme disait diane est là elle a
beaucoup soulevées pendant l'émission on
a une urgence sociale sur le sur le
territoire à laquelle il faut s'attaquer
1 et il y a des problèmes un réseau d
puissions sur la question de
l'agriculture
on a parlé des difficultés
d'accompagnement des dossiers dead qui
sont traités temps payé traite 1 de
l'absence de préfinancement des dossiers
et ce serait bien qu'on arrive qu'on
arrive à mettre en place ce moment face
à la première
diamant transiger à peu près la même
question imaginons que vous soyez
vraiment en capacité de répulsion des
décisions ou d'aller prendre vous même
si vous êtes réélu je ne vous ai pas
posé la question de savoir si vous être
agréable puisque vous le serez
certainement n'est ce pas ça me fait
gagner du temps quel ou faudrait-il
pente est véritablement le gros effort
pour les gros efforts
alors je veux quand même dire que c'est
mon premier mandat
oui et c'est mon premier mandat et
j'avais décidé à un moment donné vous
savez d'arrêter de regarder derrière les
écrans comme on fait le match où on
n'est plus sélectionneur que le
sélectionneur
on n'est plus entraîneur que
l'entraîneur enfin derrière notre écran
est derrière notre télé on était sûr on
est sûr d'avoir les bonnes les bonnes
idées est de savoir comment faire donc
j'avais décidé de franchir le pas et de
décembre
jouer le match bon décembre jouer le
match un match qui se voulait collectif
et donc j'ai trouvé auprès de mes amis
de bas pays en chance il ya le mot
plaisir
une confiance qui m'a été qui m'a été
pente et parce que c'était la première
fois et on me connaissait pas et j'ai
trouvé quelqu'un qui m'a fait confiance
qui nous a donné à chacune des
responsabilités des missions et des
objectifs et nous devons essayer de
faire au mieux pour tenir nos objectifs
mans ce que j'ai vu en décembre
en descendant jouer le match c'est qu'on
n'est pas dans un match collectif on se
prive de l'intelligence collective le
mois jeux lego le si ça vient pas de moi
c'est pas bon si c'est pas moi qui pose
sur la photo c'est pas bon j'ai vu ça
donc moi je fais en témoigne et simon
c'est mon expérience c'est mon premier
mandat
voilà et j'ai envie de jouer un match
collectif où on estime que chacun peut
apporter sa pierre et que si chacun
apporte sa sera encore meilleur est
encore plus beau bon
donc c'est la première chose dont wii
sous la condition que nous soyons dans
une méthodologie dans une dynamique dans
un esprit différent ça ça me semble
important et puis sur qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire
eh bien écoutez on a des urgences la
crise a fait apparaître des urgences ce
qui arrive auront un mandat qui seront
qui sera encore plus long puisqu'il sera
de 6 ans 9 mois d'où le fait qu'il faut
que vraiment les gens s'intéressent à
cette élection mais on a des urgences
j'en ai parlé sur le sur le social on
peut en parler sur le domaine de la
santé
on l'a vu le domaine de l'eau le domaine
de l'assainissement par beaucoup de lomé
de l'assainissement collectif
ça aussi c'est une priorité et puis j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure du tissu associatif
où il faut vraiment travailler avec eux
en leur donnant des objectifs clairs il
s'agit pas que chacun monte son
association sinon on n'y arrive pas
sinon on s'aime mais on mène pas une
politique publique se met un type pas en
tout c'est pas mener une politique
publique claire
donc j'espère qu'on aura des politiques
publiques
claire est sur le domaine du logement où
j'ai eu aujourd'hui beaucoup un vrai en
représentant la collectivité auprès des
bailleurs sociaux
j'espère que le projet d'accession
sociale à la propriété et de la création
de la coopérative l'accession sociale à
la propriété que j'ai proposé en 2018
verra le jour
parce que je trouve que c'est
intéressant au delà du locatif de
permettre aux martiniquais qui n'ont pas
les moyens d'accéder à la propriété
parce que voilà c'est peut-être ma
sensibilité de maman mais c'est ce qu'on
lègue c'est ce qu'on peut laisser tu
vois ma maman me disait tout le temps au
moins ou niant toit en les têtes ou non
ces paniers en toi ben j'espère que ces
projets là ben voilà on n'a pas pu les
faire j'espère qu'on va les faire et
voilà de la cohérence de la clarté une
vision globale des étapes un cap des
objectifs est encore riche quand ça va
pas mieux que vous n'avez rien contre st
non pas du tout vous savez
notre majorité a apporté un projet et
quand je dis notre majorité
je me donne trois là dedans parce
qu'elle fait partie de la majorité
elle a porté le projet comme tous ceux
du grand ensemble est pour bat pays en
chasse un kilo d'aucune existe je suis
politique il il a fait en tout cas il ya
quand même un bilan résultat qu'on peut
mekla devant la populace la population
elle-même elle voit ce bi la doc mon
mouvement politique le cncp apal est
prêt à continuer avec le grand ensemble
et qui porte un projet continue à porter
ce projet qui apporte des solutions aux
martiniquais sur des problèmes qui
existent depuis des années et que on
n'est pas encore arrivé à résoudre comme
les cas que j'ai cités là le lycée
chercheurs ou l'autre à sport un projet
qui consolide la conscience
martiniquaise ça c'est important
comme ce que nous faisons dans le
domaine de la culture du patrimoine
un projet qui met le martiniquais en
situation de responsabilité pour
résoudre ces problèmes et pour répondre
à ses besoins
comme on a fait dans le cas des médecins
cubains il y avait des besoins exprimés
par le chu et la clinique saint paul on
a répondu à ces besoins de a à z
on a assuré depuis le transport
l'hébergement et les salaires des
médecins
l'histoire des médecins cubains
s'étaient pas de voir vos pouces juan y
est enfin officiellement ces boues
soigner les maux a indiqué mais c'était
surtout pour montrer que nous sommes
martiniquais en situation de nous
prendre en charge de a à z
voilà ce que je voulais dire que on peut
moins acheté des du vaccin québec qui
sont cons de finalisation absolument que
les vaccins français n'arrivent pas à
enfermer ses marges
je parle bien besoin s'ils ne vais pas
de vivre mais sous la carapace qu'il n'y
a pas de vaccin français aussi bien
contre le
le virus alors vraiment les deux trois
dernières minutes de l'émission qu'on
ramène un b vous deviez tout à l'heure
que c'est votre première un premier
mandat électif au mur expérience
politique vous hésitez encore à savoir
si vous êtes candidate
qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est-ce qui vous
convaincrais de 10 part entière et quels
arguments par enterrer votre décision
je crois qu'il faut vraiment que ça se
fasse avec avec des personnes qui ont
qui ont envie de faire différemment eux
personnellement je ne supporte plus les
plaignants telle qu'elle se passe depuis
plusieurs mois lorsqu'on a une activité
à côté
enfin je lis tout je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure on peut on peut pas en fait
commencé une plénière un 10 heures du
matin finir à 2 heures du matin et
reprendre le lendemain matin à 7 heures
c'est c'est juste impossible et puis
derrière suivre les commissions aller
dans les organismes dans lesquels on
siège et le faire correctement que c'est
une chose d'y aller et le faire
correctement
c'en est une autre donc déjà pendant
c'est peut-être là la politique globale
du territoire différemment avec avec
aussi et je crois qu'on en a besoin
là nous les jeunes s'en sont fait un de
jeunisme
c'est de la transmission il n'y a pas de
transmission on regarde la moyenne d'âge
à l'assemblée oui au conseil exécutif je
n'ai absolument rien contre le fait que
des personnes beaucoup plus âgée que moi
au contraire mais il y en a il ya un
pourcentage qui est très important et
puis et puis on sent qu'il n'y a pas de
renouvellement et on a on a besoin nos
jeunes d'avoir de la transmission des
personnes qui sont là depuis 10 20 30 40
ans et qui ont appris finalement de tout
de tout ce cheminement la sent on en a
besoin la transmission et puis la
deuxième chose là pour moi la politique
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas forcément
réservé uniquement à des personnes qui
ont fait de la politique toute leur vie
parce qu'à un moment forcément elles ont
commencé elles n'ont pas fait à la
naissance au biberon et et là il ya
peut-être aussi la nécessité la
nécessité de faire entrer des personnes
de la société civile qui ont kiki qui
sont parties prenantes de la société qui
ont qui ont des avis qui sont en fait
dans le quotidien
et voilà et pour lui en faire pour leur
donner envie je pense qu'il faut aussi
repenser l'organisation au sein de la
collectivité
voilà très bien m'écouter mercy corps à
bienabe diane montrose et marylène et
hautain c'est ainsi que nous terminons
aujourd'hui face à la première qui était
réalisé par claudine et elle est belle
et jean-louis bongo vous retrouverez
l'émission demain sur notre site
internet martinique la première point fr
en podcast audio et vidéo dans quelques
instants ce sera le journal de la
rédaction de martinique la première pour
les dernières informations
je vous donne rendez-vous volontiers
dimanche prochain avant de nous séparer
mais damas qui nous écoutent et
messieurs également comme pour illustrer
les efforts de la 7e toutes tendances
politiques confondues je propose cette
citation de m'utiliser en tirer de sa
pièce la tragédie du roi christophe sur
le site un pas un autre pas encore notre
pas détenus en gagner chaque pas à
bientôt
face à la première
[Musique]
a three mis à l'eau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]